creative has been in the game for a long
time now and fun fact they're
Singaporean and super affordable here
are our picks from them the move will go
with one hell of a rugged portable
speaker that gets the job done with 18
hours of battery life and ipx7
waterproof rating if you plan to bring
it out to the Great Outdoors and you can
pair up two of these to blast fish this
would be the speaker for you at 119
Singapore dollars if you need a separate
pair of earbuds for working out likeaidu
the creative sense more ads will be
right up your alley they've got ANC
ambient mode and sensible mode which is
five times more sensitive than ambient
mode so if you go out for a run you can
remain alert while enjoying your tunes
and these also go for 1190 if you have
your dream PC setup you definitely need
speakers for watching videos and playing
games the pedal Pros are swapped to
compare speakers that come with huge
sound Bluetooth and even RGB and these
Global 89 Singapore dollars remember you
don't need to spend a lot to get great
sound you just need to know where to
look and